well our schedule has been released
thursday september 9.
the cowboys
visiting tampa bay to take on the
buccaneers the defending champions last
season ended in tampa bay the new season
begins
fire the ship throw a football into the
fire
let's go
put your patches on your generals jacket
that's right let's go baby
get your patches over your eye let's go
last year we were supposed to have
fans
for the rams game that opened the
stadium cowboys rams week one it's bears
rams
this year week one sunday night football
by the way the full schedule will be
released
on nfl network tonight at 8 p.m but all
of week one is now out biggest season
ever literally
17 regular season games that's
272
total
it's gonna be great and it gets started
thursday september 9. buccaneers hosting
the cowboys on nbc chris hey i like this
cowboys buccaneers game peter king
guessed earlier this week it was gonna
be the bills or the cowboys i like it
with the cowboys because they've got the
offense
to
to to match up sure with the bucks and
you've got dan quinn running the cowboys
defense he's got a bad history with tom
brady a little bit a chance to rectify
super bowl 49 and to rectify super bowl
51
and it's the cowboys it's the freaking
cowboys the cowboys have cache you may
as well play this game early instead of
late in the event the cowboys are four
and ten if the game is set for december
yeah so get it right out of the gates
cowboys bucks i love that choice i'm i'm
not against that either i mean like when
i first i was like oh the cowboys okay i
mean all right but okay i mean you can
get behind it for sure i the more i've
thought about it the more i actually i'm
with you i like it too i mean
the weapons they got on the offensive
side of the ball
you know dak press got that story line
of him being back after the gruesome
injury everything like that yeah you're
kicking off the super bowl for the bucks
and like you said really the big
question in the matchup is just
the cowboys defense will they be able to
stand up to that buccaneer's offense and
match them that way so uh i there's
there's been a lot of fascinating things
you know as far as this matchup's
concerned and yeah i think it's a pretty
good one when you just talk about pure
star power
and this would be the first time ever
that thursday night opener happens in
the same stadium where the super bowl
the super bowl the last year had been
played so
uh and and
we'll be there and look florida stadiums
would be full they'd be full if they
played the games right now so that's not
going to be an issue right we're going
to be in tampa and everything's going to
be open and that stadium is going to be
rocking and they're going to raise the
banner and they're going to get to
properly enjoy tom brady being the
quarterback of the tampa bay buccaneers
i i just think it's going to be it's
going to be crazy great great game and
it should be a high scoring game
and hey the buccaneers
you know when tom brady joked a couple
of weeks ago that he would trade two
super bowl rings for a perfect season
that's the one thing he hasn't done and
and look look it's it's not easy
by any stretch but they won eight in a
row once they got their
act together i almost said a different
word that ends in t after the bye week
last year they are on an eight-game
winning streak they are bringing
everyone back ostensibly they should be
able to hit the ground sprinting in
2021. it will be interesting to see
if number one they can win in week one
and they'll be favored i figured it'll
be five and a half six and a half point
favorite maybe yeah i bet the line's
already out there i'd say that's what
it'll be but they'll be favored in
pretty much every game this year
and uh it'll be interesting to see how
long they can ride that eight-game
winning streak from last season chris
yeah no i mean listen i mean they peaked
at the right time and it's a new team so
it's not like it's like oh well okay
we've been dominating football for like
a few years we could take our foot off
the gas pedal
no i think they had just gotten to the
point where they were like
you know
hey we're finally playing you know full
team football and he's cohesive and
hitting on all cylinders and it was just
getting fun we were we were just getting
going so i think there is real momentum
to capitalize on and the other thing
like i'll say with the chiefs last year
after they won the super bowl i don't
think this is a team in tampa
that's like gonna buckle under the
pressure or buckle the fact that they
have like the bullseye on their back
being the super bowl champ i don't i
think the
they got a lot of personalities there
that i think relish the limelight and
they got a coach who
i think for these type of situations
gonna be just right and be like hey just
go out there and play loose and let's be
us don't have to worry about being
perfect and over the defending super
bowl champs and you know bruce erin's
not going to put more pressure on the
situation so that's where i look at it
too to like like to what you're saying
mike i i would expect them to hit the
ground running and rip off some serious
wins here early on in the year what is
it what are the pete what are the the
bucks got they got the nfc east and then
what afc division is it this year afc
east they've got the afc they got both
east they got both these okay so that'll
be that'll be and their extra game the
the 17th game is a trip to indianapolis
a place where tom brady has played and
lost in the past a super bowl a playoff
game the colts i love that i love that
tom brady is facing the colts as this
extra out of schedule 17th game it is
it's a nice little nice little wrinkle
there is history there of course between
the colts and the pats and brady and
everything that went on with with
everything the games on the field off
the field whatever uh but yeah i'm
pumped i really am that's gonna be
awesome to see that like we know super
bowl stadiums are always electric when
they raise the banner and all that but
this is gonna be another
another level up i think because of like
what you said these people haven't got
to see brady yet they haven't been there
i mean that that place that that damn
ship in the end zone might you know fall
off and start sailing down the river
it's so loud there in tampa they are
going to be so juiced and pumped and
ready to go for that game
it will be amazing to see so good for
them that fan base deserves it and here
we go bucks are made
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports